[Music]  look the gun is on the other side it's  right there  [Music]  stay in the back  grab it  hey look out the window  welcome to my party guys  [Music]  thank you so much for having us this is  my chance to reconnect with the girls  did mom shoot someone's face this little  bump right here that's you  i still miss her every day  [Music]  i've never seen anything like this  multiple attacks  without eating a spray  lies don't do that  at least no lion i've ever seen  [Music]  go back to the calls  slow down  we're in his territory now  it's the law of the jungle  it's the only law that matters  i need you to trust me right now  i'm coming back  don't you move  he  okay  [Music]  you